Brian May was named best rock guitarist
of all time by Guitar World we did make
a point of catching up with Brian who
happened to be up at Sirius XM and uh we
asked him about this honor and he was
very humble he he didn't put much
credibility in it what's my reaction to
being named guitar world's greatest
guitarist of all time
everything like that with a pinch of
salt really because you can't say who's
best
the nice thing about guitar playing is
that everybody's different you can't
really rank people you know of course I
got my favorites too that's going to be
the next question on a but the fact that
people you know put me in that position
makes me smile is a lovely feeling yeah
it's very nice and then they got it
somehow I remember these lists come out
I say why we can enjoy all of them why
do we have to now have one be the best
of all time because that's what we got
to do for people we also asked Brian who
he considered to be the greatest guitar
player of all time and his list did
include uh Eddie Van Halen as well as a
Nuno Bettencourt which I've heard his
name before he's from extreme but uh
here's what Brian had to say I'm not in
the first million guitarist in the world
I know that it's not a chance there's
people I listen to every day who do
things that I could never do no no I
listen a new number to gorgeous and
I just smile because it's so beautiful
and it's so way out of what I could ever
do it doesn't bother me because I don't
feel in competition I just love the guy
and I love what he does same with Jeff
Becks same with Ed Van Halen we work
together and it was the most wonderful
experience my jaw dropped every time he
touched the strings you know but it was
just beautiful so there are so many
wonderful guitarists Steve Vai it's just
colossal beautiful and of course I still
have my old Heroes Eric Clapton he's
still my hero Jimi Hendrix is still my
hero of course it's always going to be
that way Jeff Beck
to me is something so exceptional on the
outside anything you could have imagined
he did tell us his personal approach to
guitar playing his technique here you go
all I ever did really was
play the way I feel
and make the guitar my voice I play like
I would like to sing I'm not the world's
greatest singer
not the world's greatest guitarist
either but thank you for saying so but I
can speak with the guitar I can I can
make it sing and that's that's all I do
it just comes from inside and
um
I don't think any guitarist should feel
like they have anything to prove it's
not a competition you know Kirk Kurt
Cobain is a great example you know
there's not a lot of technical stuff
there you know and he didn't work that
hard at being Technical and yet he gives
us a legacy of some of the greatest
guitar music of all time so it's not
about that technique it's about what you
put into it what you feel and how that
feeling gets across in your guitar
playing glad we interviewed him it seems
like he's got a lot on his mind